[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد في زيارتين مفاجئه وصل
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
الجنرال مارك ميلي الى سوريا لتقييم مهمه
عمرها ثمانيه اعوام تقريبا لمحاربه تنظيم
داعش ولمراجعه اجراءات حمايه القوات
الامريكيه من اي هجوم وفقرز رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه الجنرال مارك
ميلي صرح للصحفيين انه يعتقد ان القوات
الامريكيه وشركائها السوريين الذين يقودهم
الاكراد يحرزون تقدما في ضمان الحاق هزيمه
دائمه لتنظيم داعش ولد سؤاله عما اذا كان
يعتقد ان مهمه سوريا تستحق المخاطره ربط
ميل المهمه بامن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحلفائها مجيبا بنعم على السؤال
عن اذا ما كانت المهمه ضروريه زياره
الجنرال ميلي جاءت بعد يوم من اعلان
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه ان القوات
الامريكيه حلفائها نفذوا اكثر من اثنتي
عشره عمليه مشتركه شمال شرق سوريا في
فبراير قتل خلالها خمسه من عناصر تنظيم
داعش واعتقل 11 اخرون الى ذلك قال قائد
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه الجنرال مايكل
كوريلا قال ان التركيز الامريكي هو ضمان
الهزيمه الدائمه لداعش ومواصله العمل مع
شركاء لدحر التنظيم في العراق وسوريا فيما
اشد بكفاءه مهنيه قوات الامن العراقيه
والشركاء في قوات سرات الديمقراطيه لافتا
الى ان القتال ضد داعش مستمر
ومتابعينا في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه كشف
القيادي في تنظيم داعش ابو محمد الاردني
ان خطه الهجوم على سجن غويران كانت تهدف
الى السيطره على مدينه الحسكه السوريه ومن
ثم التفاوض على نقل المعتقلين والنساء
داعش من مخيمي الهول والروش الى الباديه
السوريه او الى صحراء الانبار نتابع
نعم المخطط ما بعد الهروب من غويران هو
السيطره على على الحسكه وتحديدا يعني
الشرقي والغربي
ثم يعني اذا تم
انجاز هذا الامر نتفاوض بما يعني حصلنا
عليه من انجازات على الخروج من المنطقه
الى صحراء الانبار او الى صحراء الشاميه
والتفاوض على اخواتنا الاسيرات في مخيم
الهول ومخيم خاصه مخيم من الروج الاسود
اخواتنا المهاجرات يعني للحيلوله دون يعني
دون
تسفيرهن الى الى بلدانهم
ملاحقه داعش في العراق وسوريا مستمره
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه ثمان واربعون
عمليه ضد عناصر داعش في العراق وسوريا
الشهر الماضي العمليات اسفرت عن مقتل 22
عنصرا من داعش واعتقاد 25 اخرين العمليات
ضد داعش مهمه لمنع التنظيم للاستعاده
قدرته على شان هجمات في المنطقه وضد
الحلفاء والمصالح الامريكيه بدون استمرار
عمليات مكافحه الارهاب سيستعيد التنظيم
قدرته على التجنيد
منذ اعلان القضاء على داعش عام 2019
انكفات تنظيم الى الباديه السوريه بين
محافظتي حمص ودير الزور عند الحدود مع
العراق حيث يتحسن عناصره في مناطق جبليه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
احمد كمال البحيري الباحث في شؤون
الجماعات المتطرفه اهلا بك من واشنطن حسين
عبد الحسين الباحث في مركز الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات اهلا بكم ضيوفي اسمحوا لي ان
ابدا من واشنطن معك استاذ حسين والسيد
حسين في الواقع زياره ملفته تطرح العديد
من الاسئله واول هذه الاسئله يتعلق بمدى
حضور داعش مدى خطوره داعش لدى الاداره
الامريكيه وان كان هذا الملف لا زال هو
اولويه لدى اداره بايدن
مساء الخير ستريم لا شك انه هذا الحضور ما
يزال مطلوبا يعني لم تتخلل الاداره
الامريكيه منذ عوده المستشارين الامريكيين
والقوات الامريكيه في العام 2014 اثناء
اداره الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما لم
تتخلى حتى اليوم عن مهمه مكافحه داعش وهي
ما تزال تعتقد انه داعش يمكنه العوده
واعاده تنظيم صفوفه لانه الحل العسكري
وحده لا يكفي المطلوب حل سياسي مرافق
المطلوب حكومات ناجحه في بغداد ودمشق وهذا
للاسف لم يحصل حتى الان وبغياب هذه
الحكومات الناجحه وبغياب حكم القانون ما
تزال الظروف التي كانت موجوده في يعني
اثناء تشكل داعش ما تزال موجوده وهو ما
يدفع الاداره الامريكيه على تمديد محاوله
ابقاء الامور كما هي عليه يعني انتصار
عسكري مع وجود عسكري يعني ولكن ليس
بالكثافه نفسها من دون امكانيه حل او حسم
او يعني التوصل لحل السياسي لكل الاطراف
طيب طالما تتحدث عن خطوره داعش خلينا نسال
للمختص في الجماعه المتطرفه عن هذا
الموضوع استاذ احمد تتذكر معنا مع بدايه
بروز وظهور داعش كنا نتابع اعلانات
التنظيم كنا نتابع دخوله لبعض المناطق
بسيارات سيل من السيارات اسلحه تكنولوجيا
كان يروج لها كذلك اليوم تغير الموضوع صار
شبه غائب حتى ان البعض نساه او انتساه
ولكن واشنطن تضعه من جديد على طويله
اولوياتها هل التنظيم نزل موجود لازال
خطير ما وجهه الحقيقي فيه 2023
يعني احنا بنتحدث ما حدث في داعش هو
الانتقال مما يطلق عليه تنظيم الدوله
سيطره التنظيم على الارض او على ما يسمى
بالخلافه المكانيه الى العوده الى التنظيم
يعني اصبح هناك تنظيم كباء التنظيمات
الارهابيه الاخرى ليس يوجد هناك سيطره على
الارض هذا لا يعني انتهاء بنيه التنظيم
وان كان حدث تتراجع شديد في البنيه
المركزيه لتنظيم داعش ولكن هناك تنامي قوي
جدا في بنيه افرع التنظيم المختلفه خاصه
في افريقيا وفي افغانستان او ما يطلق
عليها التنظيم خرسان وده ما دفع للتحالف
الدولي في سواء منذ اجتماع روما حتى
اجتماع مراقش لانشاء غرفه خاصه بالتنظيم
في افريقيا وهو ما يدل على ان التنظيم وان
كان هناك تراضع في سوريا والعراق على
المستوى المركزي ولكن هناك تنامي وبشده
وبقوه في افريقيا والدليل على ذلك ان خلال
الثلاث اشهر الماضيه منذ ديسمبر اللي عامل
ماضي وحتى الان قام التنظيم بانشاء ثلاثه
في افريقيا هو فرع الساحل اه جريدين وفرع
الساحل وفرع موزمبيقه وهو ما يدل على ان
التنظيم في حاله توسع شديد جدا في الداخل
الافريقي ومن ثم الحديث حوالين انتهاء
تنظيم داعش او تراه وتنظيم داعش على مستوى
العالم هو هناك شك في هذا الامر لكن
المؤكد ان هناك ضعف في الدنيا التنظيميه
المركزيه للتنظيم خاصه في ظل الضربات
المتتاليه لقياده الصف الاول او زعماء
التنظيم او الصف التاني من التنظيم في
سوريا او العرق
في الزياره وما مدى اهميه اجوبه كذلك رئيس
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه مارك ميل يعني هو
لما تحدث عن خطوره داعش حتى وان كان
الاستاذ احمد
فسر لنا وفهمنا كيف انه التنظيم تغير عبر
السنوات او خلال السنوات ولكن مارك ميلي
يربط بين تنظيم داعش حاليا وبين الامن
القومي الامريكي ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
يعني انه من بعد الانتصار العسكري كما
تفضل استاذ احمد تراجع التنظيم كدوله يمكن
استخدام هذه الرقعه الجغرافيه لشن هجمات
خارج حدود هذه الدوله ولكن لم يختفي
التنظيم بالكامل وهو ما يعني ان انسحبت
القوات الامريكيه او المستشارين او حلفاء
الولايات المتحده يمكن لهذا التنظيم اعاده
تنظيم صفوفه والعوده الى لعب الدوري التي
تفضلت بالحديث عنه يوم كان يعني في ذروه
وجوده ويمكن بعد ذلك هجمت ضد اهداف اما
اهداف للحلفاء الامريكيين المشكله هنا انه
لا يمكن الولايات المتحده تسليم مفاتيح
هذه المنطقه انشئنا الى اي شريك يمكنهم
منع عوده داعش وهو ما يخترق
اسمح لي بالمقاطعه حضرتك تحدثت عن المنطقه
لكن كذلك وجب التنويه بان واشنطن او اداره
بايدن
اختارت ان تتفاوض او ان تحل هذا المشكل مع
الاكراد مع اكراد سوريا
بغض النظر عن كل الاشتباكات عن كل حساسيات
هذا الموضوع عن الحسابات بين الطرفين
لماذا
الارجح لانه ليس لدى اميركا نفسها حلفاء
اخرين يعني لو تيسر مثلا التوصل الى حلول
عبر الحلفاء الاخرين مثلا ان كان اكراد
العراق وهذا متعذر طبعا لانه لا نفود
لديهم في سوريا او ان كان في تركيا ولكن
تركيا حسابات خاصه او ان كان شركاء في
بغداد ولكن بغداد نعرف انها سلمت كل
الموضوع للحشد الشعبي والحشد الشعبي يقوم
بالاستفزاز ولا يقوم بالتوصل الى حلول
ويمكنك النظر الموضوع داعش والموضوع الملف
السني لو نظرنا الى
المسيحيين في شمال العراق الغربي لراينا
انه حتى المسيحيين يعانون من مصادره
الاراضي من يعني حتى هم قاموا بتشكيل
وحدات حمايه ذاتيه ومليشيات محليه حتى
البابا يعني زارها من روما زار العراق
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع فهناك مشكله انه لا
يوجد شركاء او لا توجد حكم حكومات فعليه
يمكن تسليمها هذا الامر انا يعني هكذا
بدات الحديث اصلا وهو ما انا لا اعتقد انه
الولايات المتحده يعني
مسروره بالبقاء او بالحفاظ على الوضع كما
هو عليه ولكن اعتقد انه هذه الخيارات
الوحيده المتاحه
استاذ احمد سؤال ليبقى مطروح كذلك بين
الاسئله الاخرى هو لماذا بقي داعش ولماذا
لا زال يمثل خطوره
كما قال ميلي على الامن القومي الامريكي
وعلى العالم حقيقه
في مال كل كل يعني القوه العظمى حاولت
محاربته ولكن اليوم تضعه واشنطن من جديد
كيف يتغذى داعش لماذا وكانه وقف سدا منيعا
امام كل محاولات محاربته طيله هذه السنين
تنظيمات التي كانت متعارف عليها على مدار
الاربعين سنه او 50 سنه الماضيه في خلق
بنيه تنظيميه تعتمد على عناصر جنائيه
مستقطبه من السجون على عناصر لديها حاله
من الانتقاميه والرغبه والثعريه بشكل كبير
جدا بعيدا عن الحاله البعد الديني او
الولاء والبراء او حكم الصراع ولكن استاذ
احمد لما تعتبر بان البعد الديني هو اضعف
مكونات هذا التنظيم كيف نفسر مثلا ونحن
تابعنا منذ قليل في مقابله خاصه بقناه
العربيه مع احد الدواعش يقول بانه لو
مكانته الايام من الهروب سيهرب وان تمكن
من العوده للتنظيم فهو سيعود هناك ولاء
خاص كيف يفسر ذلك
يفسر ذلك في الكولجي ان هذا المكان هو
الذي اتاح الفرصه للعناصر لتفريغ شحنه
الغضب وشحنه الانتقام والثقريه في هذا
التنظيم لذلك
الدخول اذا المحاوره دخلت مع هذا العنصر
القيادي في بعض المنطلقات والابعاد
الفقهيه انا اشق بل اجزم ان هو لم يقرا
كثير من الادبيات الارهابيه الخاصه به بعض
التفسيرات لدى التنظيمات الارهابي ولذلك
ما زالت البيئه السياسيه والمحليه
المتواجده سواء في سوريا او في العراق هي
بيئه ملائمه لمزيد من الاستقطاب ومزيد من
الاستمرار للتنظيم لان حتى هذه اللحظه
مازال هناك حاله من الاستقطاب الطائفي
متواجد في العراق هناك حاله من الانتقاميه
والسعريه موجوده في سوريا وهو ايضا في نفس
الامر في افغانستان او في افريقيا استاذ
حسين اختم معك عن حدود الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في محاربه داعش بمعنى الى اي
مدى يمكن ان تذهب ان تصل
ان تحسب امورها
لمحاربه هذا التنظيم خاصه واننا نتحدث عن
وكانه شبه اعاده ترتيبات مع الاكراد شمال
سوريا
لا اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده ملتزمه كما
تماما حتى لو تتطلب الامر العوده الى
استخدام كل العنف العسكري الممكن بما في
ذلك الطلعات الجويه على عكس طبعا ما تحاول
اداره بايدن الاشاره في كل مره انه
الولايات المتحده تنسحب من هذه المنطقه
ولكن كل هذه الانتشارات العسكريه وهذه
المشاركات وبناء التحالفات فشي عكس ذلك
تماما فانا اعتقد المتحده ستبقى لتتاكد
انه لن تعود دوله داعش وطبعا هذه يعني
الحرب ضد الارهاب بالاشتراك مع كل الحلفاء
في الدول العربيه هي حرب مكلفه كثيرا ولا
استعداد الولايات المتحده للتراجع عنها
كما فعل اوباما في المره الاولى وفرتها
للعوده الى العراق شكرا حسين عبد حسين في
مركز الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه من واشنطن
واحمد كامل البحيري الباحث في شؤون
الجماعات المتطرفه من القاهره شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]